hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to wounded now this is a
demo they were very clear on the opening
of this game that this is a demo it
contains violence blood guard flashing
you're in the role of a father who's
returning back home from a family
gathering with his daughter Lisa both of
you are very tired and had a few drinks
back at the house making it hard for you
to continue to trip very responsible
drinking and driving a great way to
start any game so this is a demo
obviously and I do believe that it's a
Kickstarter going on right now what I
saw was very little again I was just
joking about the drinking and driving
you didn't need to actually do it that's
very bad who would ever think that after
such a great time a disaster would
happen certainly not me who would ever
think that their family dinner might be
their last gathering not me again don't
know who you're asking it's literally
only me and you guys here maybe we're
gonna see something amazing happen and
then again maybe we're gonna see
something absent what is that oh that's
my feet I thought I was seeing something
completely differently can i hello
am I getting up I better be getting up
here that better be the sounds of me
getting up and not taking off my pants
okay
barely up halfway there a little more to
go and we're gonna be great for space to
stand up okay didn't know I needed to do
that I thought I could use my legs and
such doing a lot of squat thrusts
oh hello it's my house it's lovely so
where's my daughter Lisa I am very slow
I mix I can't believe how big your
cousins are getting I know yeah the only
way I can deal with your art is if I
have a couple drinks first Oh was it
with that just standing or was it
there might be a motel over here
I hope it's a nice one I'm having a
stroke this is supposed to be happening
my memory is just fading and screaming
at me at random intervals throughout the
night well I'm kind of lost and alone
not wondering what I'm doing with my
life and looking at the interesting
architecture that I have but also why
where am I going
you wanna [ __ ] fight you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you that's what I thought run away
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you I'll
fight anything
I have just about enough of your sass
yes I just want to be very clear this is
not the proper driving form not good to
be driving like this hi can you back up
a tad I am trying to have a nap here
okay thank you
at least you listen unless you're all
behind me now that's equally is not here
I'm present space to stand up I'm ready
to get up a little bit [ __ ] you to Lisa
she not even there for the [ __ ] Lisa
sassafras did she turn into a boost
don't drink and drive kids have to deal
with the insanity of that okay fine
find a way to turn the electricity on
because that should be my main objective
what is the [ __ ] stack those flies
why are they going in a vortex formation
okay you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to wrap my head around
what the hell is happening
I mean oh so this was my responsibility
I actually am an electrical engineer and
I'm I'm maintaining the power grid on
the entire town which I happen to knock
over I think what's happening is which
is the true nightmare the horrific dream
that you have in your sleep with a
dissatisfied reality that awaits you
when you awake okay that's just
depressing we're here to get our pan
scared off of us and you're just causing
me to be sad could we I don't know pick
a theme I'm just I'm being I'm being
stupid this is actually really well done
and I like it a lot this is this is well
this is well crafted
I will admit I am at a loss as to what's
supposed to be happening but I think
that's a good thing to be honest because
wow I I was thrown for a loop like the
second I go
okay was I supposed to go up here I
don't know something is blocking the
door well [ __ ] I wasted mine and
everybody's time by going up these
stairs sure I'm glad that now they get
to talk my way back down and then
distract everybody do my objectives
really need to jump scare me is that a
hundred percent accurate all right here
we go on the correct path
nice graffiti that's some how terrifying
it makes me think they're looking at me
father and son banquet again reiterating
the family rules I don't know I'm kind
of getting it's very strange I'm getting
cry of fear vibes
wow what what the hell is coffee I don't
why is that happening
okay whatever am I going here no I'm not
let's just back it up but I I will say I
am what is that
I like how I run just like a stutter
step we're going dancing up and down
trying to get away from things okay so I
got that and I'm assuming that's gonna
because that enter I don't know what
that means yeah am I supposed to be able
to use this on the the door up at the
fire escape now
because if yes I hope that's true
because chick inside we're how do I get
inside don't tell yourself what to do I
already think you're crazy you don't
need to start talking here's okay
I should just follow the objectives
because I'm not good at coming up with
my own ideas here do I get in the motel
by going back up the fire escape
I would imagine because now that I got a
crowbar should be able to pry it open so
let's try this one I was just a little
too ambitious on my first idea Wow Wow
okay anyway I'm sorry I said this this
got off to a wild start
okay 'then this got off to a wild start
and i was not prepared for it it went
bonkers seven ways to Sunday so we're
just gonna take all a collective deep
breath and then re-engage back in the
motel because whoof it was not ready so
are you why are you whispering to
yourself who's gonna hear you
Lisa certainly is not demons might doors
locked I need a key something's blocking
something to break the lock okay got you
man this architecture sure is weird is
that grandmama sitting on a rocking
chair by the fireside okay all right I'm
down with the sickness what is okay it's
naturally going downstairs this is so
giving me cry of fear vibes
I haven't played cry of fear in so long
oh my god it's it's much more refined
than that it's so wicked oh it's so
wicked okay so I need a key card for
that I need a key for the wood upstairs
and I need to find something that can
break the door down I'm guessing I lost
my crowbar somewhere in the madness
don't know where hello is this the bed
that was on the loading screen is this
part of that madness that you were
talking about or is this disappointing
dream oh man anyway what I was trying to
say before is that I'm guessing
what is business this seemed like a safe
place for a homeless guy like me to stay
the night I said to myself who's been
abandoned for a long time and there's no
chance anyone will bother me
are you doing lovely picture some sort
of horrifying crack den well it wasn't
good okay I found a key I'll go right
upstairs
No violating I have a key
it was the door that needed a key over
here stop it with the squeaky door hello
pizza delivery
anybody a non bing-bong bing-bong
another key okay all right I can dig it
I can dig it
no one's there I'm just being a big puss
I need to sack up and get out there and
face my fears god dammit there's a lamp
there's a knee-high lamp that I just
can't conquer need to go all the way
around okay so this was the door that
something was blocked up okay I need to
break down that door but I have a key so
I imagine there's another door down
below that I could probably do because
this one has something blocked I get it
you want in I want you out so this is
keep into that okay so down here where
someone was playing the violin I ain't
afraid of thunder this should open the
door upstairs should it now but do I
want to was the big question the SAS
like old-school in the horror vibe so I
was playing around you know where it
sends you from room room finding keys
just to open other doors but this one
does it way better because it's got nice
environments well detailed places oh
grandma you're looking so alive very
strange from last time I saw you when I
was at your funeral I heard screams
what's going on I feel a hard hit in the
back of my head with a blunt object the
only thing I remember is that when I
woke up I was no room with no skin on my
body I could barely feel a thing back
and stand up turned my head to the other
side of the room where I saw a shadow of
someone stabbing needles into screaming
person's eyes
okay cool story bro but is that gonna
happen to me is f/4 cackling what's
gonna happen to me all this going on
here who the [ __ ] titty sprinkles shut
up I don't want to hear it I got duct
tape Oh dad do maybe you can fix this
fix it fix it fix it
oh I fixed it okay I had a feeling that
was gonna happen because I knew it would
probably send me back up but I probably
just missed it oh I probably missed
another scare because I was already
headed into the room I don't know
whatever it's a demo god this is amazing
I have been plated I haven't played like
a scary game like this in a long time
hello happy face how you doing this is
really cool I gotta admit this
horrifying okay oh good it's blocked off
I didn't want to go that way anyway
place is dark over here
I don't want to know I don't want to
know I just want to get to the end I
want to get out the door I just want to
get home with my life if I even have a
life left if I'm not lost in purgatory
which I'm pretty sure that's what's
happening I'm lost in purgatory nothing
here we go
damn okay so someone's been watching me
huh
someone's been watching me all right
then okay okay was that was that now was
that happening now oh okay all righty
then
so now what am I supposed to hide is he
coming you'll never get me in here
I don't know if I was supposed to go in
here okay oh [ __ ] oh okay thanks was
that supposed to happen okay what I'm
gonna do this time is I'm going to go
into the hallway I'm gonna look at them
and then I'm gonna go across the hallway
trying to get the door over there
because I'm pretty sure that's what it
wants me to do
pretty sure never mind never mind never
mind let's go okay okay okay okay okay
okay everything's fine everything's fine
and everything is a-okay
okay okay okay here we go okay we're
good we're good we were the noise in the
vent goodbye thank you okay goodbye
I fell in broke both my lights and now
I'm dead pile of meat at the borrow any
buddy home dance based
how's it going but Karina
okay little weird
Hey
I had a feel that was gonna be there
okay so that is so all the contact
information for the game is right up
there this is great
I actually really thoroughly very much
enjoyed this this was a fun adventure
I haven't played an indie horror game
like this in a long time so let me know
what you think in the comments below you
can play it for you for yourself through
the links in the description and thanks
again everybody for watching check out
the big giant playlists of scary games
that I played in the past also link in
the description and thanks again for
watching
and as always I will see